in
the rather delightful book the little
prince
there is a quotation which says
it's
only with the heart that one can
see rightly what is essential
is invisible and while the author wrote
these words
sitting in a comfortable chair
somewhere in the united states
i learned this very same lesson miles
away in a filthy dirty barrack
in an extermination camp in poland
it isn't the value or the size of a gift
that
truly matters it is
how you hold it in your heart
when i was six years old my
mother my father my sister and myself
left jew hating germany and we went to
yugoslavia
and we were in yugoslavia for seven
happy years
and then germany invaded yugoslavia
and we suddenly were persecuted again
and i had to go into hiding and i was
hiding for roughly two years
with a couple who'd worked for the
resistance
movement and i developed films and i
made enlargements
one day when i was 15 years old
i was arrested by the gestapo and
beaten up and for two months dragged
through various prisons and eventually
i ended up in a
old fortress 150 year old fortress in
czechoslovakia which the nazis had
converted into a concentration camp
i was there for 10 months i laid
railroad tracks
i exterminated vermin i made baskets
and after 10 months about 2 000 of us
were loaded into cattle cars
the doors were closed and we were
shipped east
for three days we traveled like that and
when we were unloaded
we were smelling of urine and our feces
and we found ourselves in the auschwitz
extermination camp
a camp that by that time had murdered
already over one million
people and sent them through the chimney
into the sky
we arrived we were stripped of all of
our properties whatever we had
and we're given striped uniforms we're
given a
tattoo on our arms and
we also were given the message that we
would be there for
exactly six months
and after that we would leave the camp
through the chimney
we were assigned to different barracks
and the barracks were filled with wooden
bunks
six people on each level three people
sleeping in one direction and three
three in the other direction so
whichever way you slept you always had a
pair of feet in your face
the man next to me was an extremely
nice gentleman and he introduced himself
as mr herbert levine
[Music]
mr levine was kind and polished to me
one day when i came back from a work
assignment
i climbed up i was at the top level
of the street bank and there was mr
levine with a deck of cards
and he was shuffling these cards and i
couldn't understand it you know
having a deck of cards in auschwitz was
like
finding a gorilla in your bathroom you
know
what is he doing there you know and then
mr
levine turned to me and offered me a
card and said they offered me the deck
and said pick a card
so i picked the card and he performed a
card trick
for me he performed a miracle
and i've never seen a card trick before
and the man who performed it was sitting
right there
and then mr levine did the unthinkable
he actually explained the trick to me
and the words got burnt into my brain
and i remembered every single word and
from that day on
i practiced that trick every day
although i didn't have any cards
i just kept on practicing
about three weeks later
the entire camp with the exception of a
couple of hundred of us
were sent to the gas chambers
i was sent to another camp where i
worked in the stables
and then in january 1945
when the nazis advanced and when the
russians advanced
60 000 of us were sent on a death
march and we walked for
three days on and off
and in the middle of the winter and by
the time we arrived
at the railroad siding out of the 60 000
people
15 000 had died and the rest of us were
loaded into
open railroad cars and for four days
shipped
all the way from poland down to austria
and we found ourselves in a death camp
in
a concentration camp called mao thousand
which again was built like a fortress
and at that point the
ss abandoned us and there was
no food there and there were thousands
and thousands of bodies there
i slept for three days next to a dead
man just to get his ration
of a tablespoon of moldy bread and two
days before
the end of the war may 5th
we were liberated by american forces
at that time i was 17 years old
and i weighed 64 pounds
and i hitchhiked back to yugoslavia and
when i came back to yugoslavia there was
communism there
there was no family there and there were
no friends there
i stayed there for two years and
after two years i managed to escape to
england
and when i came to england i couldn't
speak english i had no education i had
no skills
i started working and about a year
after i arrived in england i bought
myself a deck of cards
and for the very first time
i actually performed the trick that was
shown
to me in auschwitz on top of a
bunk bed and it worked
it worked beautifully and i showed it to
some friends of mine
and they loved it and i went to a magic
store and i bought some
magic tricks and i showed them to my
friends and i bought some more magic
tricks
and i showed it to them and then i
bought some magic books and i bought
some will magic books
there's a very very thin line
between a hobby and insanity
anyway i got married and i came to the
united states
and one of the first jobs
that i had demanded from me
to speak to small groups of people
and i managed it i was very good at it
and then 25 years ago i retired
and i started speaking in schools
and the only reason
why i could speak in schools is because
a very friendly man showed
a rather scared kid a card trick
in a concentration camp
the man who showed it to me mr levine
had been a professional magician he
worked in germany and when he came
to auschwitz the ss knew who he was
so they gave him some cards they gave
him a piece of string they gave him some
dice
and he performed for them
and then he also taught some of them he
survived the war but
his wife and his son died
he came to the united states and
performed in various venues
but i never met him again
but the trick that he showed me stayed
with
me and enabled me to
go around schools and try to make this
world
just a little bit better
so if you ever know
somebody who needs help
if you know somebody who is scared
be kind to them give them
advice give him a hug
teach him a card trick
whatever you're going to do it's going
to be
hope for them
and if you do it at the right time
it will enter their heart and it will be
with them
wherever they go forever
thank you
you